what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
doo doo doo it's time to play a game
what is going on members of the rock or
welcome back welcome back to our weekly
series on how to kill superheroes were
the worst villains and comic books from
gore were the worst guys we figure out
ways to kill superheroes
we're literally involved in conspiracy
to commit murder against superhero God
were terrible people now last week I
told you guys these are pretty sure I
said last week ah this week we were
going to kill Solomon Grundy and that's
exactly what we're going to do of course
last week we were talking about Lobo we
said how that was the most difficult
video that we did today and that is true
this is the most difficult video that
we're doing today and next week is going
to be even harder because next week or
the next video that we do on how to kill
superheroes I think next week I'm trying
a new video on how superheroes would
kill us but on the next how to kill
superheroes video that we're going to do
we're going to try to kill the one above
all we're going to try to kill the
literal god of the Marvel Universe and I
have no idea how that's going to happen
but this video solomon grundy is going
to be wildly difficult and to find out
why let us begin
where we always do with a brief
explanation of the character followed by
rundown of their powers so like many
comic book superheroes or villains or
what-have-you Solomon Grundy has been
reimagined and reckons multiple times
since his debut in all American comics
number 61 in 1944 so as a result his
history is a little muddled but the long
and short of it is that Solomon Grundy
started out as a guy named Cyrus cold
who was murdered in a swamp and later
came back as a zombie that he was
originally a villain that primarily
fought Allen Scott the first Green
Lantern but has since feuded with
several different heroes most notably
Batman and Superman now before we begin
discussing his powers it's worth
pointing out that Grundy is a character
who much like Lobo has been written
fairly and consistently over the years
and is for that reason
it's hard to get an exact measurement of
how powerful he is for example we know
that Glenny possesses a superhuman
strength but just how strong he is is
varied by different writers who have
handled a character over the years as
we've seen everything from Grundy
getting beaten up by Batman in a long
Halloween to possessing strength that
appeared to be equivalent to Superman
now in addition to a strength Grundy's
undead status allows him to survive
without air food drink or sleep as well
as allowing him to fight without his
muscles tiring which gives him seemingly
limitless stamina also adding to our
challenge Grundy has an extremely potent
regenerative healing factor that allows
him to instantaneously regenerate from
virtually any injury which now that I
think about it seems to be becoming a
staple of the characters that are
getting featured in the series lately
but with all that said Grundy presents a
rather unique challenge for us and that
while it is possible to overcome his
strikes seminar and healing and actually
kill runde the problem lies in the fact
that each time he has been killed Grundy
has been able to come back to life in
fact Grundy has been killed a few times
in DC colors itself once he was
dismembered by winds created by Red
Tornado which ended his life he's been
choked to death by a bowstring from
Green Arrow which doesn't make any sense
because Grundy doesn't need to breathe
and in another instance Grundy was
killed by a collapsing building now
after each of these deaths Grundy was
able to come back sometimes as a
creature with some measure of
intelligence and other times as a
mindless monster so for our discussion
today we're not really answering a
question how can we kill Solomon Grundy
because that's been done several times
what we're really trying to answer is
how can we kill Solomon Grundy and
prevent him from coming back well to
answer that we have to have a discussion
about what exactly it is that keeps
bringing Grundy back from the dead and
that conversation has to start with a
concept in DC Comics known as the green
now the green is an elemental force that
ties together all plant life in a DC
Universe and it exists in a sort of
spirit dimension that's home to a group
called the Parliament of trees now in
addition to the green there are other
forces in DC Comics such as the red
which connects all animal life and the
rod or the black that's the force for
decay now in order to keep all these
forces and balance these different
aspects appoint avatar
to operate as the protectors on earth
there have been several of these but the
most famous among the avatars of the
green had been Swamp Thing and poison
ivy however what many people don't
realize is that at one time the Green
had planned on making solomon grundy one
of their avatars by resurrecting him as
a plant elemental in the same vein as
Swamp Thing but overlooked the fact that
one crucial element in creating such an
avatar was fire now because of the fact
of solomon grundy had never been burned
by fire prior to or during his death
what this meant was that the process to
turn him into an avatar of the green was
basically a failure and the result was a
kind of half plant elemental that rises
out of the same swamp after each of
Solomon Grundy's deaths seemingly for
eternity so now that we understand why
Grundy keeps coming back we might be
able to figure out a way to stop the
process so that once we kill him he
stays dead now our first option should
probably be to see if those who created
the problem the parliament of trees has
a solution since they're the ones
responsible for creating Solomon Grundy
in the first place there perhaps exists
a way that can correct their mistake so
someone like Swamp Thing may be able to
petition the Parliament of trees to take
action and reverse the curse that allows
Grundy to keep coming back however they
can be reasonably assumed that the
Parliament is unable to do anything
about Grundy since they haven't already
either that or they simply have no
desire to do so of course if that
doesn't work our next option as it often
is is to try and use magic what all else
fails it seems we can always try and
magic our way out of a situation that's
basically DC's version of reality
working for Marvel Comics now in this
particular circumstance there is some
hope that magic will actually help
rather than basically being a way for us
to use a trump card and get out of the
situation as a last resort and the
reason why I say this is that the DC
Universe is actually home to a
practitioner of magic that has a lot of
experience in dealing with matters
concerning the green this person being
John Constantine now if you don't know
who John Constantine is he's basically
an expert on several different types of
magic mysticism and other occult
knowledge and has spent a lot of time
working with swamp Singh now because of
all this experience that he has working
with the green it's not too far-fetched
to think that he might be able to tap
into some sort of spell that he's
learned over the
years now I'll concede here that I'm not
aware of any specific spell that we've
seen Constantin use electronics that
would lead us to believe that he can do
this but since this series is by nature
hypothetical and speculative not to
mention entirely focused on fictional
characters I see this exists as a viable
option possibly hopefully if not then we
have one other option and it could be to
turn out to be our most drastic if not
ecologically irresponsible since
Grundy's resurrection seems to occur in
the same place every time specifically
in the swatter swamp
located a few miles from Gotham City it
occurs to me anyway what if we destroy
the swamp now environmental concerns
aside it could prove true that if we
destroy the slaughter swamp which is
basically the site of Grundy's
continuous resurrection that maybe he'll
stay dead once and for all now I admit
this might not work due to the fact that
as long as there's plant life on Earth
will basically be stuck with solomon
grundy dying and coming back together
all the time but at the very least it's
worth the shot now assuming that any of
these plans succeed in eliminating
Solomon Grundy's resurrections we still
of course have to find a way to kill him
but because of the fact that we've
already covered ways that he can be
killed over the course of this video we
really don't have to rehash any of that
we could just kind of go with any of the
options that we've chosen so far but if
you guys are new here to comment to
explain make sure you guys have a sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and if you have any
suggestions on characters that you think
we should kill that we haven't killed
already here in our how to kill
superheroes series post them down in the
comment section I'm curious to see what
kind of what kind of person you guys
come up with and without being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end but I don't we'll catch you all
later please
[Music]
you